yes thank you hello and thank you for
taking my call
yes ma'am 61 years old on five feet
eight and I weigh 115 pounds at about 9
and I am vegetarian
besides osteoporosis I and I take your
pig pack in selenium with great results
thank you okay I'll have a high allergy
to citrus especially lemon and limes but
my concern is that two years ago I was
diagnosed with liver cysts that was 12
centimeters and last month I had at
rechecked with an ultrasound and I was
told that it was 15 centimeters so my
question is what all does it what can
prevent it and how can it be treated
without having surgery okay did they say
what kind of sister was a simple liver
cysts okay and it could be just a one of
the bile ducts that's never had an exit
and so just by all overtime fills up
that bile duct a little tube that
carries the buyout to the gallbladder
and system that particulars --it it
started ballooning up for the bile
building up in it and it might be a
birth defect that you were born with it
could be that you actually have a
gallstone which is that not even to go
in the gallbladder yes that's a Gulf
stones are not caused in the gold but it
actually causing liver and they drop
into the to the gallbladder and it gets
blamed part but really these um gall
stones are caused in the liver so it
could be a gall so I'm blocking that
bile duct so see here and again you
weigh a hundred 115 pounds 115 yeah sure
okay don't you have any other issues you
mean have a pressure diabetes
we have osteoporosis right and a high
allergy to citrus that I've ever been
and I would like to know if you can
address that also okay Mary why don't we
suggest use this I you know go to the
medical school I know how close you are
to another's Emory University and
medical school there I know them very
well
they know me very well when I get a
second opinion from them you even have
to have the ultrasound they can make a
disk for you in and send it over and let
them look at it give you another opinion
in the meantime for a hundred and
fifteen pounds you gotta get rid of all
the bad stuff all the inflammatory
things no fried foods no processed meats
with nitrates and nitrites no oils no
olivocochlear all margins mayonnaise
hundred cooking oils and no gluten wheat
bread oats I go ahead and also because
you're sensitive citrus I would use our
original liquid multiple it's called the
ultimate classic it's a liquid multiple
and then I would also get the EFA s
so again take your body weight you can
take three of those DFAS at breakfast
free dinner time as two bottles of the
fa s per month
one bottle month of the ultimate classic
liquid take a tablespoon twice a day
that's a half ounce twice a day so the
last year month and then also I get the
ultimate enzymes balance called the gall
bladder a bottle because it does have
bile in it it'll raise your blood level
levels of bile which will get into your
liver and it has the capacity to help
you absorb the good stuff but also it
can dissolve a gall stones okay because
a gall stones are just precipitated bile
and so they get some liquid bile going
in your liver if that's all it is is a
gallstone plug in a duct you might not
guarantee but you might be able to get
it dissolved by supplementing I go ahead
and take one of those say one or two
minutes for each meal couple ounces of
water we get that second opinion give us
a call and maybe they'll have a better
insight as to what's causing that cyst
to slowly grow and it will walk you
through this